hallo und herzlich willkommen zur
heute-show unter habe ich alte
systemnutte doch direkt das erste mal
gelogen denn eigentlich ist es die heute
zum letzten Mal schon ja an diesem 15
Mai beginnt der Weltuntergang Bill Gates
und Angela Merkel fangen genau heute an
mit Hilfe unseres neuen Infektionen
schutzgesetzes einen Großteil der
Weltbevölkerung umzubringen also
verkürzt ausgedrückt steht so im
Internet muss also stimmen auch deswegen
wird ja seit Tagen demonstriert seit
Tagen allein in Stuttgart waren tausende
Menschen auf der Straße und natürlich
ist es wirklich wichtig sich für
Grundrechte einzusetzen aber wenn bei
sogenannten Hygiene Demos bewusst auf
Abstandsregeln gepfiffen wird dann geht
es wohl auch um die Freiheit andere
anzustecken dann lösen Veranstaltungen
für Grundrechte vielleicht die nächste
grundrechtseinschränkung aus
dieses Virus ist für uns alle eine
Zumutung aber kleinreden oder leugnen
hilft jetzt auch nicht wirklich weiter
man müsste doch mal jemanden kennen
sehen fühlen sprechen der Corona hat ich
kenne keinen wo ich kann keinen Kurs
Corona es soll sich bitte zeigen das
Corona soll sich endlich zeigen dann
poliere ich ihm die Fresse ja die Angst
vor dem unsichtbaren Feind darum geht es
im Kern so ein Virus ist viel zu
abstrakter also muss Merkel schuld sein
oder Christian Drosten keine Ahnung ja
man kann sauer sein weil zum Beispiel
fast alle corona-maßnahmen von
Ministerpräsidenten beschlossen werden
und nicht in Parlament ist nicht gut man
muss sogar wütend sein über die
ungerechte Verteilung von Staatshilfen
Stichwort Lobbyismus aber solche realen
Probleme sind manchen Demonstranten halt
leider ja viel zu langweilig ich will
tatsächlich das Recht haben diesen
diesen Virus zu bekommen
die Politiker spielen alle mit und
Konsorten hier Rothschild die haben sich
nicht ausgedacht hier stand
ich vorbei hier bei mir
funktioniert
das Lager die Sterne nicht an Viren die
sterben an der Angst die verbreitet wird
ich habe ein Problem
damit
ich liebe Kinder ist mir ganz wichtig
ist keine korrekte Atemschutzmaske es
wird gerade immer schneller gelockert
teilweise auf Druck von Gerichten was
beweist dass der Rechtsstaat
funktioniert warum klingen viele
Demonstranten immer noch so wahnsinnig
dramatisch alle sind mindestens
Widerstandskämpfer kleine staufenbergs
darunter machen sie es nicht nur sie
trauen sich die unbequemen Wahrheiten
auszusprechen mein Gott und noch was bei
einer Demo für Freiheiten sollten nicht
zu viele rechtsextreme auflaufen wegen
der inneren Logik das passt sonst nicht
wenn ich da die identitäre Bewegung sehe
oder Reichsbürger dann gehe ich nach
Hause oder mache meine eigene Demo auf
Punkt aber was mich am meisten
beschäftigt warum kommen eigentlich so
wahnsinnig viele radikale Impfgegner aus
Schwaben wir haben jetzt einen Regie
muss man sagen ein Regime ein
Pharma-Lobby höriges korruptes System
korruptes Regime und dieses Regime nutzt
einfach die Gunst der Stunde um ein
totalitärisch
weltweites
menschenverachtensystem zu installieren
heilungsblöchel wenn Bill Gates ein
System installiert stürzt es meistens ab
übrigens verbreitet sich der Wahnsinn
schneller als Corona nach aktuellen
Umfragen würden sich nur noch zwei
Drittel der Deutschen impfen lassen
neulich waren es noch 80 Prozent
herzlichen Glückwunsch aluhüte können
wir nur beten dass wir trotzdem noch
genug Freiwillige fürs impfen
zusammenkriegen was ist denn das Problem
geht dann könnt ihr mal sehen was da
drin ist außer affengehirne
Gänseleber Gebärmutter 12 Mikrogramm
Quecksilber und sein neues Mikrochips
Gänseleber mit Gebärmutter gibt es das
auch als Schluckimpfung wie schaffen es
diese Leute wie schaffen die das die
Bilder aus Bergamo oder New York völlig
auszublenden wie machen die das es liegt
wohl auch am sogenannten
präventionsparadoxe weil unsere
Maßnahmen funktioniert haben fühlt man
sich nicht mehr bedroht im Grunde wie
bei so einem Fallschirmspringer der
denkt jetzt ist 3000 Meter lang nichts
passiert warum soll ich da noch die
Reißleine ziehen das will die Reißleine
Industrie doch nur dass ich das mache ja
also hört man lieber auf Leute wie dr
Bodo Schiffmann
HNO-Arzt und Mitbegründer der neuen
Partei Widerstand 2020 ist das nächste
Sammelbecken für alle die mit der
Gesamtsituation unzufrieden sind Herr
Schiffmann hat neulich mal völlig
falsche Zahlen zur europäischen
sterbestatistik rausgehauen ja und
ansonsten stellt er der deutschen
Politik ja einfach nur fragen ich glaube
nicht dass erstmal ein großer Plan
dahinter steckt ich denke wir sollten
wenn die Sache rum ist politisch
aufklären ob ein großer Plan dahinter
gesteckt hat welcher Plan schön wäre es
große Pläne erkenne ich hier eher selten
bei uns können sich nicht mal
benachbarte Landkreise auf eine
einheitliche corona-strategie einigen
Plan also 2020 sie merken es wirklich
ein exquisiter wutbürgerjahrgang ganz
vorne mit dabei ist sogar ein echter
Veganer Koch Atilla Hildmann ja Atilla
Hildmann hat möglicherweise ein paar Mal
zu oft seinen Kopf in den Thermomix
gehalten anders sind solche Bilder hier
jedenfalls nicht zu erklären da übt er
am Schießstand wohl für den
bevorstehenden Bürgerkrieg um unsere
Freiheit ist übrigens eine schwierige
moralische Frage darf man als Veganer
eigentlich auf Menschen schießen und ist
veganes Essen nicht Waffe genug auch
hielt man glaubt dass Bill Gates uns
allen Mikrochips einpflanzen will und
wenn wir das irre finden dann ist das
unser Problem ihr müsst kapieren
Verschwörungstheoretiker ist die neue
Nazikeule ja soll mit ihren Scheiß
Keulen so unsere zu mir kommen mit ihren
scheißdrecks kommen diese ganzen Schafe
die nur nachplappern nee nee mit
Tagesschau sagt so ich sage auch
Tagesschau wie die Tagesschau sagt nee
genau mehr macht die Tagesschau wo fuff
macht das heute journal so kann man es
unterscheiden gut klar hat Attila
Hildmann keine Angst vor Corona als
Veganer weiß er ja gerne ins Gras und
das war der dritte miese Veganer Witz in
nur einer Minute Leute wir haben so
drauf hier garantiert nie im heute show
Fanshop
koch dir die Rübe weich mit Attila
hildmanns leckersten Rezepten gegen die
da oben Klassiker der wutbürgerlichen
Küche wie
zwangsgeimpfte Bilderberger Klopse Pizza
Illuminati belegt mit verkohltem
Grundgesetz und Ganzen Chemtrails das
wird man ja wohl noch essen dürfen oder
warum nicht mal ein halbgarer
Reichsbürger schön im Untergrund gegart
und zum Nachtisch von den Regime Bullen
zusammengeknüppelte Erdbeeren mit
Pfefferspray Attila hildmanns Koch
Bestseller mein Mampf für alle die nicht
an die Menschen gemachte herderwärmung
glauben
es gibt tatsächlich mittlerweile eine
ganze Armee von aluhut Promis sido ist
dabei ein gewisser her Kollegah Xavier
Naidoo die große alte Dame der Welt
Verschwörer oder zählt Schweiger der von
sich sagt ich bin Team Xavier wobei
Schweiger ist wenigstens nicht
ansteckend denn beim nuscheln stößt man
keine Aerosole aus plus natürlich Promis
von gestern wie Eva Hermann das braune
Schaf unter den Tagesschau wetterrahmen
äh in München fängt man damit an dass
jetzt Kommandos durch die Straßen gehen
und
wahllos klingeln bei irgendwelchen
Leuten und die Spritze dabei haben und
sagen wir wollen euer Blut abnehmen das
ist nur zu eurem besten
richtig und diese Leute nennt man
Vampire Vampir Kommandos in München
genau so arbeiten verschwörungsfristen
in München soll eine Studie klären wie
viele Menschen symptomlos an
corona-erkrankt sind dafür wurde an
Haustüren Infomaterial verteilt und
freiwillige konnten sich dann
telefonisch melden ja daraus macht Eva
Hermann die Merkel sa tritt uns die Tür
ein und saugt uns das Blut weg wer
steckt hinter all dem wer sie ahnt es
Bill Gates ja Bill Gates nicht lachen
das sind alles erfundene Tatsachen auch
Angela Merkel empfängt jeden Morgen ihre
neue order von diesem Mann ja die sitzt
da immer kurz vor sechs am Telefon und
wartet auf den Anruf ihres Gebietes und
dann diktiert Herr Gates ihr die
tagesbefehle ja also welche Grundrechte
sie heute abschaffen soll welche Drogen
als nächstes in unser Trinkwasser
eingeleitet werden und wie viel deutsche
Kinder geopfert werden damit Bill und
seine Frau deren Blut trinken können die
merkel muss die Kinder aussuchen das
grauenvoll grauenvoll ja und dann
befiehlt er ja noch 300 Kniebeugen
einfach weil das kann
zum Glück zum Glück hat Dennis knossalla
jetzt eine Partei gegründet die Bill
Gates Weltherrschaft beenden wird sie
nennt sich Aufwachen 2020 jetzt geht's
los Herr knossalla ich sehe sie tragen
auch den berühmten alu-bommel das
Erkennungszeichen des neuen Widerstands
aber nur ironisch wir truiser tragen den
Bommel ironisch um uns über dieses
aluhut Klischee lustig zu machen
und mein Bommel leuchtet auf wenn
Echsenmenschen in der Nähe sind Sekunde
sie scheinen in Ordnung zu sein Gott sei
Dank sag mal warum diese Dämonisierung
von Bill Gates diese ja diese Bill Gates
Besessenheit also Entschuldigung die
Verbrechen von Bill Gates sind Legion
das beginnt schon mit Windows 95 das
hätte mich damals fast in den Selbstmord
getrieben und genau das will er ja Bill
Gates will die Weltbevölkerung auf
maximal 500 Millionen reduzieren hat er
gesagt hat er nicht darf ich bitte
Ausreden sie Faschist maximal 500
Millionen und die Überlebenden werden
Zwangs geimpft damit er noch reicher
wird deswegen hat er sich ja die WHO
gekauft damit er alles bestimmen kann ob
Sie Urlaub machen können auch mit dem
Auto in Österreich ja oder nein das
bestimmt nicht sie die diese Regierung
gewählt haben das bestimmt nicht sie die
diese Regierung finanzieren mit ihren
Steuern nein das bestimmt aktuell
Belinda Gates aha und wenn ich gar nicht
nach Österreich will das ist Bill Gates
scheißegal wenn der sagt Österreich dann
fahren Sie nach Österreich und jodeln
ist alles Bullshit Bill Gates hat nicht
die WHO gekauft ja
9,8% der zweckgebundenen Spenden bei
denen stammen von seiner Stiftung und es
wäre besser die WHO würde nur von
Staaten finanziert alles keine Frage ist
doch kein Grund den man auf Demos mit
Hitler gleichzusetzen Fake News Fake
News Fake News der wird gar nicht mit
Hitler gleichgesetzt nicht alle hier
stören sich an diesem Vergleich
richtig vollkommen richtig der Mann ist
schlimmer sie sagen Bill Gates ihrer
Mama
eindeutig ja gibt es unter seriösen
Historikern gar keine zwei Meinungen was
wäre das denn für ein Scheiß Plan vom
Gates wenn ich mit Zwangsimpfung Geld
verdienen will warum Rotte ich dann
vorher über 90% meiner Kunden aus weil
ja das hätten sie eh nicht verstehen
Gates hängt noch in ganz anderen Sachen
mit drin ich sage nur kuhan und
Verschwörung sie kommt aus den USA und
besagt dass eine Pädophile Elite
angeführt von der Familie Clinton
jüdischen Bankiers und Hollywood
Schauspielern Kinder weltweit entführt
und ihnen einen Stoff namens adrenochrom
erpresst eine Art Lebenselixier
gut das klingt schon viel plausibler
kurze Nachfrage wenn Bill Gates ein aus
gefolterten Kindern gewonnenes
verjüngungselektieren nimmt bis hierher
folge ich noch warum sieht er dann so
aus da würde ich aber mein Geld
zurückverlangen ach welke und wie der
sieht er die offensichtliche Wahrheit
nicht die Frage ist doch wie sehr der
Mann aus wenn er kein adrenochrom nehmen
würde
[Musik]
also Bill Gates ist sicher alles andere
als ein Heiliger Stichwort Monopol
Missbrauch unfaire Geschäftspraktiken
hat nicht umsonst Milliarden Strafen
gezahlt warum muss man sich da noch
Schwachsinn dazu ausdenken wie er will
uns allen einen Chip implantieren warum
sollte er weil er böse ist hier ich
zeige Ihnen mal die Beweise im Internet
die die das ZDF nicht senden darf im
Moment was Windows Update nein nicht
jetzt nein Alter verdammtes video
[Musik]
ja
IT-Service brunsmeier sie sprechen mit
Jürgen wie kann ich Ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das Gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe ja probieren Sie doch
mal den Kanal der heute Show auf YouTube
zu abonnieren
genau und im Zweifel ruhig auch mal den
Gefällt mir Button klicken genau ja ich
bleibe in der Leitung